hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking with Randy Barnett
he's a Georgetown Law professor and the
author of the book most recently our
Republican Constitution securing the
Liberty and sovereignty of We the People
Randi thanks for talking great to be
here Nick all right well let's get right
to the book
our Republican Constitution Republican
is not capital R it's not a partisan
thing you talk about a democratic
constitution and a Republican
Constitution understanding what is the
democratic constitution and why is it
important the two different conceptions
of the Constitution stem from two
different visions of what we the people
means we the people could either be
taken collectively as a group and if
it's taken collectively as a group the
only way we the people can govern is by
Democratic majority arianism so it leads
to a democratic conception of the
constitution and meaning like deimos or
the mob I mean that the majority rule
yeah and the majority the only if if the
concept of popular sovereignty means
that we the people must govern then the
only way we the people can govern is by
a majority rule right and then it's
through representatives who themselves
are supposed to represent the majority
view so then what's the Republican
counterweight well it's interesting one
of the reasons for writing the book is
that this other democratic vision of We
the People is so obvious and all known
that people can't even imagine what the
alternative might be but it turns out
there always was an alternative and it's
We the People based on individuals or
what I say is we the people each and
every one if you take the view of We the
People each and every one is individuals
and you follow the Declaration of
Independence which I have a chapter
right devoted to it's that first come
rights and then it is in the words of
the Declaration to secure these rights
you mentioned the the Declaration of
Independence but first off why why does
the Declaration of Independence matter
in relation to the Constitution because
the Constitution is the founding
document of the United States of America
right not the Declaration well the
Declaration was the founding document of
the country then we had the Articles of
Confederation and then we had the
Constitution we had two different forms
of government here since we separated
from Great Britain but the reason why I
appeal to the Declaration is because I'm
trying to show that this individual
conception of We the People has as long
a heritage as the democratic or
majoritarian one
the one that we the people is a group
and you see it in the declaration it is
to secure these pre-existing rights that
governments are instituted among men if
you take that view then it's not so much
that we the people govern that's not
what happened that's not what popular
sovereignty means popular sovereignty
means that it's the rights of the
individual person that needs to be
protected by government and then the
people control or they limit government
but government is not the same as us
they're a small subset of us they're the
governors and the reason we have a
constitution is to provide the law that
governs them this is not something that
necessarily follows in terms of
conservative or liberal conceptions
right because somebody like Robert Bork
a very conservative jurist was in most
ways of majoritarian that as long as you
know if a law was passed by an assembly
or a legislature that had been properly
elected they could pretty much do
whatever they wanted yes I mean this is
a book it's a popular book that we
should point out my other books have
been more academic published by Oxford
or Princeton this is a popular book
published by Harper College intended for
a general audience and if I had to say
who the direct target of the book was
and in some sense who the audience is
it's conservative Republicans or it's
conservatives in the United States today
who have accepted in some sense
unthinkingly this progressive or
democratic vision of the Constitution
and made that part of their own there
there are sometimes no more strident
adherence to the Democratic Constitution
than some judicial and Servat of
Republicans and talk about that in terms
of you use the terms or the phrases
judicial restraint which I think people
are somewhat well known are versed in
and then judicial engagement as opposed
to judicial activism but judicial
restraint is part of the democratic
constitution judicial engagement part of
the Republican right because judicially
the reason the argument for judicial
restraint is that unelected
unaccountable judges should not
beginning in the way of Democratic
majorities unless they have some really
good reason for doing so for example if
the Constitution has an express
prohibition the Constitution itself
speaks for the majority so judges can
follow that this is a very majoritarian
view of what judges are supposed to do
leading to a doctrine of judicial
restraint which is not an interpretation
of the Constitution is simply a vision
of what judges
Rolle is judicial engagement which is a
term that has been popularized by the
Institute for justice is the idea that
judges and as explained in the book
judges are to our servants of the people
and their job is to be an independent
tribunal of Justice when a member of the
sovereign public gets into a dispute
with the legislature who are their
servants as to whether the legislature
is acting within its proper powers the
public ought to be able to go to a
neutral judge who's not going to put his
finger on the scale for one side or the
other and have that issue determined and
that is what we're calling judicial
engagement talk about how this also
intersects with concepts of original
intent or originalism because these are
also phrases that for those of us who
are not trained in law you know it it
gets difficult to understand it's very
simple this is the Constitution if the
Constitution is the law that governs
those who govern us then those who
govern us should know lot more be able
to change the law that governs them then
we are able to unilaterally change the
speed limits to govern us they need to
go through the amendment process so
originalism is simply the proposition
that the meaning of this must remain the
same until it's properly changed and
then it's explained in the Constitution
how those changes right exactly
now this is not a book this is not a
book about original Russell my last book
was about a rationalism originalism
plays very little role in this book but
it is underlying the whole idea of why
we have a written kind of important to
understand Okun ilysm the way you're
talking about it it's not like they're
biblical literalists and they're saying
if you know it's in the Constitution or
not I mean the specific words or things
like that it's actually about the
process by which laws or by which the
scope of government is amended yes the
argument is that the were every word of
the Constitution should be followed
right according to the meaning it had
when it was enacted and it was enacted
at different times the 14th amendment
was enacted in the 1860s so it is about
following the words of the Constitution
it is not about following the intentions
of those who wrote the words in the
sense of what they expected would happen
is what's sometimes called original
expected applications it's not about
that not about well what would they
think
about gay marriage or what would they
think right about freedom of contract
that's not what this is about it's about
what they said not what they how they
thought what they said might be used in
the future
you've talked in the past or you've
written about how bizarrely I mean now
it seems and it's it's partly a tribute
to Antonin Scalia the recently deceased
Supreme Court justices impact before him
there wasn't all that much attention
paid to the actual text of the
Constitution or of laws being written
how did that happen and then how was it
through force of personality that he was
able to say hey look you know we're
supposed to be reading this stuff I'm
not exactly sure how it happened but I'm
certain that did happen when he became a
justice the court was paying almost no
attention to the text of the
Constitution you could have whole big
Supreme Court opinions that didn't even
talk about the text and what it might
mean that's no longer the case the
variable I think that's changed here is
Justice Scalia and Justice Thomas
together
joining the court because justice
Thomas's every bit as much a committed
originalist if not more than Justice
Scalia was and now recently Justice
Alito has just revealed that he himself
is also originalist he was out of I was
on a program with him at Georgetown I
introduced him and the Dean was asking
him questions just like this and he
asked him what his approach to the
Constitution was he says well I'm an
originalist
and that's the first time that I've
heard him describe himself as an
originally where does Scalia fall in the
realm of judicial restraint versus
judicial engagement he's kind of in the
middle he I think because of his history
he came through up through the restraint
period and restraint period still
affected him but I do think that he was
pretty stalwart about where there is an
express prohibition an expressed right
in the Constitution that it ought to be
enforced with qualifications that he
also believed in like standing
requirements and other things and so he
was kind of in the middle of this and
there are some like a professor for
example judge J Harvey Wilkinson who
have argued that even the Heller
decision protecting the individual right
to keep and bear arms and the Second
Amendment is an activist decision so
that that's the extreme deference that
once pervade
the conservative legal movement but no
longer pervades the conservative legal
movement before we go on to talk about
your specific experiences in four cases
argued in front of the Supreme Court I
let me follow up when you talk about the
Fourteenth Amendment and you add 1516
that at a certain point when the Bill of
Rights was applied to the states broadly
speaking what is left for the states to
do if in fact they have to defer to the
United States Constitution well plenty
in fact it's just discussed in the book
and chapter nine I think where I talk
about irrational and arbitrary laws the
Constitution and our whole system of
government presupposes that our
liberties may be regulated but those
regulations have to be for the purpose
of protecting each one of our rights
each one of our liberties and so
regulations are sometimes which you
might think of as before the facts
saying afterwards you could you could be
sued for tort but before the fact you
shouldn't be able to build a building
that doesn't meet certain kinds of
standards this is not a libertarian
world necessarily but it is a world of
reasonable regulation but if the
regulation is not reasonable if it's
actually irrational or arbitrary meaning
it isn't really there to serve the
health and safety purposes of the public
but maybe it's there just to help out
certain interest groups as opposed to
others then that's beyond the just
powers of a legislature to enact
legislators must be trying to regulate
to protect against harms caused by
individual conduct in good faith not
simply to help out their buddies how is
the discovery process of that though is
it is it the results or is it you know
in legislation where you are in the
legislative history and I know one of
the examples you talked about has to do
with I wear like restrictions
state-level restrictions on you know on
what is Italy optical yes that's right
yeah so you know and this is going back
a few years before we had you know
various kinds of lens crafter or
national chains and there's some of
these laws still it kind of exists of
where oh you can't just sell your own
eyeglasses you need to go through this
rigorous and ridiculous state licensing
process at cetera et cetera
why isn't you know why do we know that
it's a ridiculous or arbitrary restraint
on economics there on business rather
than something else
I think courts need to be realistic
about the origins of these laws but then
with that realism in mine then they just
have to look and see whether there's
some kind of fit or what kind of fit is
there between the means that were
adopted in the ends that they're
supposed to achieve if they find that
fit is not really there or if they find
that certain people are being treated
differently than other people for
reasons that can't really be explained
that's what an irrational and arbitrary
law is an irrational law is one that
doesn't really fit the purposes you're
literally acting irrationally you say
you're doing it for this reason but it
isn't really doing it or arbitrary
because you're treating this person
differently than that person similarly
situated those that's sort of the outer
boundary of what the people can be said
to have consented to when they're not
being asked directly for their consent
can we ever separate out you know that
sense of well this is you know arbitrary
or this is ridiculous from social
context because when you think of
something like Plessy versus Ferguson or
some of these economic rights cases
where it's like no well you obviously
you shouldn't be allowed to sell caskets
to somebody out of state or whatever you
know these seem ridiculous now the idea
that you would say okay well you know a
black man can't buy a first-class
railroad ticket but in 1896
you know maybe nobody would you know
very few people would have said oh
that's totally arbitrary where it does
lots of people a lot of people said it
was arbitrary the railroad companies
didn't like the idea of having to put on
separate cars and make their employees
insult their customers by telling them
they had to ride in the second car a lot
of people objected to it by that point
the Supreme Court had basically enforced
the democratic constitution which
deferred to local police power
majoritarian rule and the rationality of
that statute in Plessy was treated in
two sentences in that opinion that
basically it was to preserve social
order and a story no discussion of
context no discussion if there had been
a problem with social order beforehand
which there hadn't been and so that's
exactly the kind of deference that my
book argues against and I talked about
blessing in the book well let's talk
about the Obamacare
decision you are and you know possibly I
mean this reads almost like a legal
thriller the opening section of the book
is phenomenal in and it recounts your
role in coming up with the legal defense
or the legal argument against the
individual mandate and Obamacare which
obviously didn't go the way that most
libertarians and I would hope you know
most Americans actually want the idea
that we can be mandated to engage a
certain type of economic activity
against our will you've written that
Obamacare is actually a partial win can
you explain what you mean by that right
well you have to distinguish between the
law and the outcome normally if you win
on the law you also win on the outcome
and if you lose on the outcome it means
you've also lost on the law this is a
very strange circumstance where we won
on the law and still lost on the out
okay so I mean because the win on the
law was what you just said government
does not have the power to make you buy
a good and service that the five votes
agree with us about that
they said it's beyond the commerce power
it's beyond the commerce power as
enhanced by the Necessary and Proper
Clause it's an improper means of
Congress asserting its enumerated powers
we want we want and then what Chief
Justice Roberts did is he changed the
law so that it wasn't a mandate anymore
it was an option it was an option you
can pay this small tax that's
non-coercive in his opinion had to be
non-coercive otherwise it's it is it
non-coercive because it's small yeah
exactly so at what point when it build
up - Chief Justice Roberts you can ask
I'll get him on he's coming in next yes
and and I'm sure he has a book to
promote no are the legal challenges to
Obamacare done well because it's such a
big law it's constantly gonna be bumping
up against one provision of the
Constitution or another right now we
have the religious exemption issue for
some people for paying for abortions and
our abortion related services so a big
law like this is constantly going to
have problems but in terms of we're not
going to get rid of Obamacare in the
courts that's the will happily we've
done legislatively yes at all right and
one of the purposes another way in which
our case was a win it was a big win on
the law we would have made terrible law
if we if the court had adopted the
government's reasoned for a poll
Obamacare but they didn't they adopted
our reason but it's another wind because
we kept the law in legitimacy limbo for
several years and in some respects it's
still a legitimacy limbo normally once
the social welfare program gets
implemented politically it's completely
impossible to repeal it but our lawsuit
was part of what kept that law
controversial to this day and recount
how you came up with the you know what
was the kind of light bulb going off
where you realize okay there is a you
know that the individual mandate is
really up for questioning in a serious
way it happened on a blog I was on the I
was a member of the politicos blog
called the arena I don't think it exists
anymore and one more and there'd been a
Wall Street Journal piece on why
Obamacare was unconstitutional which had
not persuaded me and then I woke up in
the morning and I checked my handheld
and I saw that there was a very snarky
post by this law professor about why no
serious person could question the
constitutionality of this which got me
kind of riled up you know I sometimes
get that way you know it was wrong and
you just had to find the know I just say
oh come on this guy's like you know he
was equated the Constitution with the
Supreme Court he said the Constitution
the Supreme Court has given up blah blah
blah and it just annoyed me and so I
thought okay fine let's start with what
the Constitution says it's not in here
anywhere and it's sort of like one thing
led to another as I was crafting this
blog post it's just sort of the argument
just sort of got made in the course of
writing a blog post now in the book you
talk about how you were happy not to be
the one actually doing the oral argument
and my wife was really happy but that
leads to a different case that also has
a lot to do with the commerce clause the
rage case about medical marijuana in
California whether or not the federal
government had the right to regulate
that and you did argue that yes and that
one went against you six to three if we
won in the Obamacare case how did we
possibly lose in the rage case it's
actually a completely different legal
issue there was nothing improper about
the means that Congress was using the
only it to enforced its law which is the
normal criminal law to enforce the
prohibition the only issue is whether
they could reach inside a state and tell
individuals
what to do because their conduct would
affect interstate commerce survey
pathetically yeah cuz I mean this is
it's hard to say that anybody grown pot
in their backyard is really affecting
that's to you that was our argument
that's what we said well you've won and
we've got and we've got three votes we
won justice O'Connor over and Justice
Thomas and Chief Justice Rehnquist we
had all three of them you know but we
lost Justice Scalia and it took me a
while to get over that yeah I wrote a
pretty harsh treatment of Justice Scalia
after that and we lost justice Kennedy
for reasons he never articulated he just
joined the majority opinion never defend
himself and basically what Justice
Scalia did getting back to your earlier
question is he deferred to Congress's
judgment that you needed to reach
homegrown marijuana in order to
effectively regulate interstate commerce
so it's when he took the deference turn
that's when we lost him yeah so it comes
back exactly to that point and your
question earlier about whether he's a
deference guy or not he was a deference
guy when it wasn't in that case as it
was in other cases and then in other
places he was like no the government
just doesn't really can't legitimate a
right to right right but you know he
changed you know we've all changed we
all change I've changed and he's changed
he was growing in in mine what I would
say my direction but at the same time I
started off not being an originalist and
became an originalist after he did and
so in some respects I kind of grew a
little bit in his direction what you
know just personally what is it like I
mean you talked about it's it's
nerve-wracking to be in front of the
Supreme Court but it's also kind of what
you know that's like being on Broadway
if you're a lawyer what's it like to
lose I mean how does that you know is a
crushing is it like a you know we in
that case we knew I knew we'd lost
because I could tell from the tenor of
the questioning that we lost I you know
after weeks of past before the opinion
came out I could convince myself well
maybe Justice Scalia really wasn't gonna
vote against us after all maybe he was
just asking me questions but I knew that
day all the questioning that I got from
the bench were from people justices that
voted against us the three friendly
justices Chief Justice Rehnquist was
sick that day so
didn't ask me questions Justice Thomas
doesn't ask questions and for whatever
reason justice O'Connor didn't choose to
give me any helpful question so I had a
very hard day I think I held up but
under severe questioning and I knew in
the Obamacare case the we felt we wanted
and in fact reporting shows we did win
it so how do you know want it initially
and then just Chief Justice Roberts
changed his vote after this how do you
know that I mean is that from a textual
analysis or are you reading key leaves
there it was reported by a reporter a
very good reporter of the Supreme Court
from her sources that this is what had
happened and do we know why he changed
his mind we don't because it's a secret
that even they had even changed his mind
and no and her sources didn't didn't say
yeah I only know what I know from her
sources
it does Roberts tend to be deferential
to it see a democratic constitution yeah
exactly and he was recently in the gay
marriage case and and he talked about
how evil Lochner was in the gay marriage
race explained for us Lochner well
Lochner is this famous or infamous case
from the night early 1900s in which the
Court invalidated a maximum hours law
for Baker's and it really wasn't that
big a deal at the time but Teddy
Roosevelt and I talked about this in the
milk actually Teddy Roosevelt made it a
campaign issue when he ran for president
as a progressive in 1912 and he made
judicial restraint a big theme of his
movement and he he had put Oliver
Wendell Holmes on the Supreme Court when
he is president as a Republican and
Holmes had this hugely restrained
outlook towards what judges should be
doing and it's bit just to keep it
straight in my mind it's just that if
the legislature does it it's okay right
oh only if if no reasonable person could
agree with it is it not okay but there's
always a reasonable person like
Justice Holmes would say well I'm a
reasonable person and I think it's okay
so they're first okay so unless you can
unless just a law that no reasonable
person could possibly think was within
the legislative power it's okay
and so Teddy Roosevelt when he was
running for president and he was quoting
Holmes and talking about judge Holmes
and how to great just as he was he
started talking about the bakeshop case
and made it a big political issue
and he was mad that they hadn't
validated that the Supreme Court had it
invalid right the Legislature's right to
say no you can't work more than a
certain number of exactly right and so
he made it a big public issue and from
then on in it had a sale a political
salience that it didn't have really
before 1912 and for many on the right as
well as people on the left the Lochner
case is the paradigm example of the
Supreme Court having overreached right
in a very very inappropriate way and I
remember when I was a law student and I
got to that case and I was reading it in
the case book and I would read for
tonight before I had Larry tribe as my
Khan law professor it was an excellent
teacher and I would be reading the cases
and I would come across a case like the
Lochner case and I don't specifically
remember that one but I know the whole /
thing I read it I go wow this is great I
can't believe how great this opinion is
and then I would like turn the page they
but it's evil yeah this is why it's
wrong wait wait I don't know wait a
second I like that case so I do i do say
somewhat tongue-in-cheek but only
somewhat that it's my favorite Supreme
Court case and that just gets the dander
up and you obviously never worked in a
bakery or for a Dunkin Donuts or
something I worked in a laundry okay so
there you go so he was very hot in that
laundry to switch gears a little bit you
have in the in the long let me say this
new off the Lochner case and this goes
back to your statement about what
reasonable regulation is and what it's
not what's irrational the lot that
particular provision was part of a very
large and comprehensive regulation of
bake shops called the bake shop Act
there were all kinds of health and
safety rules in that act how high the
ceilings had to be whether the floors
what the floors had to be made of
whether the ceiling the walls had to be
whitewashed what kind of animals could
be in the vicinity cats only where the
washrooms would be what the ventilation
would be where people would sleep
relative to where the bakeshop
that were that where the ovens were all
of this was in the act none of it was
challenged all of it is mentioned in the
majority opinion as perfectly okay
reasonable regulations in the health and
safety this one provision only which was
put into the law at the behest of the
bakeshop unions was singled out because
it did not have an obvious relationship
to health and safety and the arguments
that were being made on his behalf the
court thought were not credible no why
because it really they knew and in fact
the evidence show
that it really was there to hit side
with the the bit the organized unions in
the bigger bakeshop case it big the
bigger bakeries right against these
small mom-and-pop ethnic bakeries that
didn't want to unionize so that's what
the court was getting in the middle of
there was that sort of controversy
because it lacked a health and safety
rationale they didn't uphold it but they
they in fact it wasn't challenged but
they mentioned that the rest of the act
was perfectly fine so I just want to say
the supposed extreme Lochner case
they're the worst of the worst of the
worst as far as they were concerned the
health and safety regulations of the
bakeshop industry was perfectly okay
where would you be if you were deciding
that now because you know what did I
mean would you would be okay and this is
also in the 19-teens this is you know
when cities are filling out factories
and large buildings are first being used
in cramped quarters there's things like
the Shirtwaist triangle Factory fire so
would you be okay with a lot of these
other safety regulations as a matter of
the United States Constitution including
the 14th amendment if I were a judge and
those were good faith health and safety
regulations I would have hold them you
know that's what the Lochner Court did I
would do what the Lochner Court did and
that shows how reasonable I am well to
turn to a slightly different topic where
you may not be considered as reasonable
in your in your career as a legal
scholar and as a commentator as a
radical libertarian you know person
you've always looked kind of ask ants at
the libertarian party or third parties
in general right and that they're kind
of distractions from where change is
really going to happen a couple weeks
ago and USA Today you wrote that if
Donald Trump wins the Republican
nomination much less or wins the
presidency that a third party should
crop up you said it should be called the
American Constitution Party Why should
there be a third party and what should
its basic principles first I should say
that when the libertarian I wasn't smart
enough to know all this when the
libertarian party was formed I was
robbed the libertarian party I went to
the libertarian party national
convention in New York and I don't
remember who the candidate I have to go
back and check which candidate was
nominated there but that's the one where
ed crane was involved in Murray Rothbard
was involved in Robert Nozick was still
involved in
Libertarian Party was very exciting to
be a part of all of that and I cast a
vote I think for Roger McBride back in
the day so this has not always been a
few but I have subsequently come to
realize that we have for better or worse
a two-party system based on the laws
that govern our elections gonna have two
dominant parties the laws are rigged for
a two-party system unless you change the
laws this is what we've got and the
winner is the one that's the
first-past-the-post they get the office
and so if you have a third party it's
generally going to pull votes away from
the party it's closest to and help the
party it's farthest from so the logic of
a third party makes it more likely that
you'll get the worst candidate of the
two major parties will get elected okay
so that explains why you're against
third parties in general so what is the
specific threat that is you know that is
posed by Donald Trump because he's an
authoritarian who doesn't believe in the
Constitution or anything other than his
own ego and and we know those happen
from listening to him just okay listen
to what the man says if he doesn't keep
his story straight from one minute to
the next minute he says whatever pops
into his head at the moment he's a
dangerous demagogue and I if I were
somebody who cared about the immigration
laws the way his supporters do I
wouldn't trust general Trump to deliver
anything for me because he'll just make
a deal he's already basically announced
that at any rate he's a dangerous
demagogue and costing him the election
is a good thing what do you think about
somebody like Ted Cruz you know Harvard
Law grad talks about the Constitution in
between you know every other sentence
every other word he like he has
essentially the same immigration policy
he wants to kick out 12 million people
he says Trump is soft on immigration
because he would let some of those
people back in how would we enforce a
law like that without becoming an
authoritarian government and also if
Trump and I think you're right he
clearly doesn't give a [ __ ] about the
Constitution he probably has never read
it any more than he's read you know both
books of the Bible
but you know Cruz has said it he's
against birthright citizenship Cruz has
said that he believes in retention
elections for judges how is that
different from kind of Trump ignoring
the Constitution well first of all as
you know I was an advisor to Senator
Paul during the campaign before his
campaign ended and I was one of the
people in the room helping prep him for
debates my opinion of Senator Paul
continued to go up the more I was around
him and also I can tell he's a very
independent-minded fellow he he took our
advice under advisement but I liked him
so much and so that was my first choice
I think I know I know Ted Cruz and I
have a lot of respect for him I think
he's first and foremost a
constitutionalist and for example when
he was asked about the gay marriage case
a gay marriage issue privately he was
being secretly recorded in a New York
fundraiser and he was asked about this
privately and what is the answer and the
person who was questioning him said was
this part of your just one of your top
three priorities well you would say the
politically correct answer and
conservative Republican circles is to
say yeah but that's not what he said he
said no and the person who questioned
him said well what what do you mean he
goes the Constitution is my top priority
and under that vision under his vision
of the Constitution marriage is this
thing for states to decide so then why
was he back in Kim Davis he was on a
stage with her the Kentucky County
Commissioner look I can't speak to
everything that Ted Cruz does but I can
tell you that his position was that that
marriage laws that the Supreme Court
erred in taking marriage laws away from
the states I had a brief in the Windsor
case that argued exactly that arguing
the steep the DOMA is unconstitutional
because DOMA takes the Defense of
Marriage Act is unconstitutional because
it takes marriage away from the states
where it belongs and so his position on
gay marriage constitutionally is the
same as what might possess so was the
constitutionally yeah the so the
difference between so many like Ted Cruz
and Donald Trump despite many
similarities and policies and you know
preferred outcomes necess
Arlie is that he believes in the concept
right and I think he will appoint judges
who also believe in the Constitution now
we could go back in if I have a doubt
about him it would be back to our
restraint mm-hmm versus originally
because he the Amazon a lot about
unelected judges well I don't know if he
does I take your word for that I haven't
seen him yeah Murr about that but the
but I don't do that
but I would say that just knowing his
history I would sort of presume without
knowing that maybe he's part of this
restraint tradition that so many people
like Chief Justice Roberts is but look I
think that Obamacare gets got back to
that for a minute I think that
politically that decision was a
watershed moment it was a defining
moment a critical moment in our
intellectual history our political
history up to that point restraint
everybody was sort of on board with that
after that point building up to it they
restraint didn't look so good and well
the one thing Ted Cruz has admitted he
was wrong about and he doesn't admit
he's wrong about very much it was his
support for Chief Justice Roberts he
says that was a mistake
that's huge since he doesn't admit that
many mistakes word going through a kind
of non confirmation confirmation period
do you think that of Mike Mike section
made in law school merit guard okay well
I was going to ask you is what is
Merrick garland Supreme Court worthy and
is it wrong to deny him even a
confirmation here Merrick garland who
was my classmate was one of the stars of
the section he was one of the Gunners in
the class that would challenge the
professors the entire year we all looked
up to him and a couple other people who
were like in that upper echelon in a
very very decent human being would be a
wonderful adherent to the democratic
constitution mm-hmm
he is a deference guy par excellence he
defers to the EPA he defers to
administrative agencies that guy defers
like crazy and for that reason as a
matter of judicial philosophy I think he
would not be a good justice for us to
have so I would be opposed to him what I
but my character and fitness grounds and
ability grounds yes but you see
part of the problem is evaluating
justices on basis of quote so-called
qualifications as long as everybody was
an agreement in the democratic
constitution the post New Deal
understanding of what constitutions
should be which Republicans and
Democrats were all in agreement about
then at that point all you're interested
in is qualifications how smart are you
how good are you because everybody
basically agrees but now we have a
fundamental disagreement about the
Constitution starting with the Scalia
appointment and I mean to some extent
with Rehnquist but also this Rehnquist
and Scalia then Thomas we have a
disagreement about the Constitution now
qualifications aren't enough what you
need is what Joe Biden used to say you
have to look for and that is judicial
philosophy and that gets us back to
originalism that is what a justice
should be an originalist first and
foremost let me know and this so let me
just say qualifications are necessary
but they're not sufficient this is a
political question not a legal one or a
judicial one but does it make sense for
then is it legitimate for the Republican
Senate essentially to forestall to run
the clock out on Garland's appointment
or confirmation possibility you know it
is it is it oh is it legal to do that
and I guess it is but is it proper to do
that simply because you don't want to
give the sitting president it's every
bit as constitutional
it means it's completely constitutional
in fact I haven't heard a serious
argument nope nobody makes a serious
argument that it's not constitutionally
permitted it's all an argument about as
you say whether it's proper or not right
and the Senate is is entitled to veto or
fail to consent to an abdominal is to
select somebody this is what the Senate
did not the president did not select me
mm-hmm
or someone like me he selected my
classmate merit yeah and therefore he
discriminated against me he chose he and
he went with Merrick instead and it's
perfectly appropriate for the Senate to
say we disagree about him and whether
there needs to be a hearing or not
actually at that point I would say there
should not be a hearing because given
that we are in the election cycle given
that this appointment is going to last
far beyond this president Stan
here and it's something that ought to be
made an issue at the next election it's
something that the people as voters the
electorate should have a say-so in how
this courts going to look in the future
can we talk a bit about how you
developed your ideas and in the larger
libertarian legal movement a couple of
weeks ago at the students for Liberty
Conference George well was on a panel
with myself and Matt Welch and it among
will was totally pessimistic we were
saying okay well what's what's next for
the libertarian moment and he's like no
no no we're in an authoritarian moment
one of the few bright spots is the
libertarian legal movement led by people
like yourself what is the libertarian
legal moment and then movement rather
and talk a little bit about how you how
you became part of it and what what it
actually what constitutes it well first
of all I should mention George Will
wrote an extremely flattering laudatory
that you didn't get a chance to read
because it wasn't in the pre media in
the galleys but I've read it and it's
you know it's like wow I mean I would
never have had the nerve to write this
about myself so I will forever be
grateful to George Will for this and he
is somebody who's kind of moved from a
majoritarian perspective to the idea
that the Constitution is a rights
document that really puts limits on
government and and as his conservative
critics will remind him whenever he
speaks on behalf of judicial engagement
well nope they'll trot out all the old
quotes from the Nixon days in which he
was going the other way and I mean
that's kind of the nub of a libertarian
legal movement right I mean it's it's
your definition of We the People as
individuals as opposed to a kind of
majoritarian democratic constitution
right well this is this book is somewhat
of a manifesto for that although Clark
Neely's book terms of engagement is
really a manifesto for that this is
something a little bit broader and
bigger but along the same lines it is
intended to be a manifesto for what you
might call the right of the American
political spectrum
it's arguing why there uh no there
should unreflective had adherence to
this progressive idea of judicial
restraint and only enforcing the
enumerated rights and not protecting
Liberty generally is something that a
conservative should be
for it's an it's an argument for that
side of the political spectrum and as
you say it's an argument for political
action I mean the hope was it would come
out earlier than this and it would
somehow inform the political debate
we're now having hopefully coming out in
April before the November election will
be soon enough to have some influence so
but talk about where you where you came
from you know when I was asked our in
around and we've engaged each other over
the years and whatnot but you know on
Wikipedia I know you were born in 1952
I'm not even sure where your hometowns
not listed you went to Northwestern as
an undergrad Harvard for law school you
taught at Kent College of Law which is
part of the Illinois Institute of
Technology Boston University or at
Georgetown right you were big in the
Federalist Society you have connections
to the Institute for Humane studies I
was at Cook County State's Attorney okay
there's no prosecutor in Chicago from
1977 to 81 all right so he's born in
Chicago okay and and where we get a were
you always libertarian inclined yeah and
talk about your early entry into that
kind of work I was a Liberty there's
like two general strains of conservatism
tradition based in Liberty based and I
was a Liberty based one I got my
principles from my dad that's where they
came from what did he do he was a in the
laundry business that's how I ended up
working laundry and his definitely know
you you couldn't sue to have a cap on
your dad I was very wonder there's no
air conditioning back then in the summer
so on the south side of Chicago is where
his business was I grew up in a place
called Calumet City which is a South
suburb is a very working-class
blue-collar primarily Polish Catholic
town on the border with Indiana most of
the people there worked in the mills or
in the refineries in Northwest Indiana
and as when I was 12 years old in my
junior high school I debated in front of
the entire student body on behalf of
Barry Goldwater and I remember I had to
ride a bicycle there was no Republican
there's no internet so they get
information you couldn't get from the
media so I had you have to get it from
the Republican and there were not
Republican also in Calumet City I had a
riot ride my bike over to Hammond and go
to the Republican office and pick up a
German idiot Hammond Indiana and to get
this information for my debate I
actually found my notes
my debate in my in my files I have it so
that's who's so Goldwater was like
fantastic
what what what extremism in defense of
Liberty is is no vice
right moderation in pursuit of justice
is no virtue and what you know do you
think libertarians are born or made or
is it a combination because obviously
you said your father was kind of he was
a proto libertarian he became when I
became a real libertarian in college I
expected to go home and get an argument
from my dad because my dad was extremely
opinionated he was a very he really
argued he always won he was always right
so it always made it difficult to argue
with although it was handy because if he
told you something you could rely on it
being true but he actually changed to be
a real libertarian and then I was
libertarian rather than kind of
tradition yes yeah and so I had a long
struggle with a with a junior professor
at Northwestern about libertarianism
what did you major it philosophy okay I
started off as political science but I
discovered that it was all statistics
and empirical stuff and I thought it was
gonna be political theory but it wasn't
so then I went to philosophy and it
really was fantastic changed my life and
I probably prefer I'm sure I'm a
professor today because of that and so I
argued with this John Cody who was a
junior classics professor at
Northwestern for about nine months and
he he would carry you know Mises around
with him with his or Anarchy state and
utopia around with he's marked up
something and we had this debate we
would meet periodically in debate and
finally after about nine months I
thought well maybe he's right and maybe
I'm not right about this and that's when
I became a libertarian and by my senior
year I taught a student organized
credited seminar in my residential
college on libertarianism where I taught
the course Wood Wood years I was a
college from 70 to 74 so I would have I
would have taught that course in 73 or
so what was it like to be a libertarian
back then because it was you know there
was a New York Times magazine story and
70 or 71 about libertarianism what's the
next big thing Libertarian candidate in
1972 got one electoral vote
Nathan yes sir first the first woman to
get an electoral vote so what I mean
what's it a sense where you want did you
feel like you were on the vanguard of
something or did you feel like you were
out in the wilderness or oh I felt like
it was like when you joined the federal
society as a student you find there's
other people here that are like me I'm
not alone and so there were other people
I was so not on my own at Northwestern
and then I wrote a fan letter to Murray
Rothbard saying I'm going to Harvard Law
School maybe someday I might meet you
but here's all the ways in which you
influenced me he didn't respond but he
gave a copy of the letter to a classmate
of mine John Hagel who at that time was
president of a new organization called
the Center for libertarian studies in
New York and John called me up and he
was a first year law student along with
me and we got to know each other and
then we got tight and then he brought me
down to New York and that fall of my
first year of law school is when I met
Murray Rothbard
at Fordham where Leonard Lydia was
giving a lecture and Murray was in the
audience and that evening we actually
ended up John and me and Murray in
Murray's living room quizzing him about
the hypotheticals that we were that were
tormenting us as losted what can you
remember any of them no all I can
remember was his reaction which was I'm
sitting there in law school hearing all
these hypotheticals about is this right
is that right and I figured well as a
good libertarian I should have a
libertarian answer but I didn't have one
so I thought well that's on me
and then we both of us gave him these
hypotheticals and Murray Rothbard mr.
libertarian he couldn't answer him
either
and that actually planted the seed that
wait a second maybe these principles are
general and they don't answer super
specific questions all the time maybe
there's a difference between law and the
more general principles of justice we're
trying to see effectuated but that was a
very memorable moment and then I joined
the board of the Center for libertarian
studies which was a superstar roster of
academics and maybe it's not a good idea
to have a board of directors be all
academic intellectuals because they tend
to fight a lot but Murray was there
Murray was on the board in other people
like Ronald Hammond Bill Evers and
there's just a it was just an all-star
lineup and eventually Charles Koch
joined our board and that's when I first
got to know Charles well and talk about
that because you also have connections
with the Institute for Humane studies
which has been around since the early
60s and I know I benefited from it you
did as well and it helped create
a funding source as well as an
intellectual resource for libertarians
that wouldn't be there otherwise well I
just told you that in I came down in the
fall of 74 to New York and met Murray
that was my first year of law school
later on that year Murray recommended me
for a fellowship from the what was then
called the law and liberty project run
by a man named Davis Keeler because they
had a summer fellowship program and he
recommended me for this program and then
IHS gave way I didn't know about HS but
I just gave me this fellowship and it
was that summer I wrote my paper
restitution a new paradigm of criminal
justice that was published in ethics by
the time I was a third-year law student
so my becoming a philosophy major is
what first planted the seed of being a
professor of something I thought it
might be philosophy and then writing
this article was my first experience
doing scholarship and that came about as
a result of Murray Rothbard recommending
me to the Institute for Humane studies
so had it not been for IHS giving me
that fellowship I don't know if I'd be
sitting here today
talk about Murray Rothbard a bit as a
person he is a you know he was part of
virtually every aspect of the
libertarian movement while it was around
and he also alienated virtually every
aspect of the libertarian movement what
was what is your memory of him and
obviously you gained a lot of energy as
well as insight from him but you know is
there more to say about him he was an
amazing man I still consider myself
basically a rothbard Ian he has a so you
define well it's basically property
rights are sort of the core of what
Liberty is about I ended up getting into
a debate with Ronald Dworkin Dworkin was
my jurisprudence professor in law school
about the relationship between property
and live Liberty and he said to me
privately says well you're not a
libertarian
you're a proper terraeum because
property is fundamentally and that
really also got me thinking and I wrote
a paper about that for Dworkin but so
that's really sort of the Roth party and
I mean that and other things are the
rough Bardeen perspective so he had a
huge impact on me
he was a wonderful guy or he could be a
wonderful guy he also had kind of a dark
side that some when you deviated from
whatever he thought was the line he
allowed a certain amount up to a
but beyond a certain upon a point you
kind of were dead to him in a way and at
some point I crossed some line and I was
no longer at one point I was his
fair-haired boy so to speak and along
with others and at some point I wasn't
anymore but I never stopped caring for
Murray
you mentioned Robert knows that as well
and if he was very decent to me when I
was a law student also knows it yeah but
yeah well who were the other kind of
intellectual lights that lit up your
night sky
well not Nozik was not one of them I
mean we who were Rothbard Ian's looked
askance a bit at this Anarchy state and
utopia business and it may it put
libertarianism on the map in philosophy
and had a huge role to play and deserves
he deserves a tremendous amount of
credit for the respectability that
libertarianism now has in academia but
the book itself has issues and I wrote a
critique of the book actually early on
so he would I wouldn't say that Robert
knows it was a big influence on me but
Murray was definitely one and eventually
Hayekian thought I only saw I never
really met Hayek I was actually on a
boat cruise with him one time and Mont
Pelerin Society and so he was sitting
next table over I took a picture of him
that's the closest I came what had
define how do you mean by Hayekian
Hayekian ISM has to do with evolutionary
notions spontaneous order something that
really is plays a big role in yhs
mmm-hmm intellectual agenda and so it
and you know back in the days when I was
really in Marie's camp
I mean Marie didn't care for Milton
Friedman very much and Marie didn't care
for Hayek very much and so we didn't
either but I changed my mind about but
then the idea of Hayek is that you don't
need as many top-down regulations or you
need just a few and then you kind of let
a lot of experiments play out and people
will adopt what works and let go well if
you look at my book the structure of
Liberty which is my take on why we have
the rights we have from 98 yes yeah and
but a new edition just came out like a
year or two ago with a new afterward so
it's actually available in an affordable
paperback edition because the other one
was getting unaffordable and
the first part of it is really Hayekian
it has to do with the it says that we
have the rights we have because of three
basic social problems that every society
must confront problems of knowledge
problems of interest and problems of
power well the problem of knowledge was
Hayek yet this notion that we need a
discovery mechanism to figure out to
aggregate and somehow coordinate what
all of us knows given how ignorant we
are everything else that we don't know
and in the economics or that's what
prices do exactly and I defend that I
use that price mechanism in my book so
the first part of it is very Hayekian
but then it's tempered with other
insights that were the problems of
interest in the problems of power go
beyond what Hayek is talking about but
it's that book is an attempt to sort of
bring into under one rubric most of the
major arguments for Liberty and to show
how they relate to each other not to say
there's only one argument but there are
several because the rights we believe in
solve multiple problems in multiple ways
and so there isn't just one reason why
they're good there are multiple reasons
right talk about Charles Koch he's as
somebody he is
you know funded many many institutions
on the libertarian dial or you know in
the libertarian aisle let's say what
kind of impact do you think he's had
overall on the Liberty movement well as
I said in and I hadn't seen him for I
don't know 30 or 40 years from the
Center for libertarian days until
recently and I introduced him when he
was getting an award and I said well you
know back when I first met Charles I was
just a law student and he was just a
millionaire we've both come a long way
since then and I have a world of respect
for him I think what's happened to him
what the left has done to demonize him
is absolutely wrong I mean he has to
have security with him at all times you
know there's been all these terrible
threats to him and not only do you have
activists threatening him which is bad
enough but you have government officials
singling him out by name for abuse and
such as government officials president
the president the president or
presidential candidate like Hillary
Clinton singling him out by name and
this is just wrong in a republic
should not be happening and so he is the
victim of terrible injustice and the
ironic thing about this is that he isn't
the right-wing conservative he is a
libertarian well that's what's
interesting it's there's kind of a
Streisand effect going on where the left
needed a villain in many ways the right
did this with George Soros you know a
decade ago yes no but rightly so well I
was gonna say but it it brought more
interest into Charles and David Koch and
David sits on the board of trustees of
Reason Foundation and suddenly you know
you find out these guys are libertarians
they're not conservative right then it
blows people's minds because they're not
really bringing their minds to this
question you begin with talk about the
federalist society because the
federalist society clearly has had a
major role in kind of temperate or not
tempering but bringing a new set of a
new set of conversations and debates to
legal education you were a very active
in it from what I understand when you
were teaching at Boston University and
you still are but what what is it roll
then well it's at a libertarian legal
the Federal Society has had a hugely
formative role to play on me I probably
wouldn't be teaching I wouldn't be a
constitutional law guy if it weren't for
them because I started off as a
contracts guy as a law professor because
when I took constitutional law and I was
turning the page of the con law book all
the good cases were bad cases all the
good parts of the Constitution turned
out not to be mean what we thought they
meant the Second Amendment the Commerce
Clause nothing so I said look if the
Supreme Court is not going to take the
Constitution seriously why should I and
given my radical libertarian background
this was not a hard conclusion for me to
reach and so when I became a law
professor sty with a criminal lawyer
which is what I went to law school to
become a criminal lawyer and I did that
I was a prosecutor and then when I
entered academia I did as a contract
scholar because writing still matter law
still matters I believe in freedom of
contract that's how I started and then I
got invited to a federal Society
national student symposium the fifth one
on the First Amendment held in Stanford
and I was invited by a student who I had
met through IHS and he was at that point
he went on from Harvard MBA to Stanford
Law and he invited me and I said you
know Bryan you know I
do the Constitution so you know I don't
want it he says well you know you're a
smart guy
you only have to talk for 10 minutes you
can think of 10 minutes of something to
say and it was a conference on the First
Amendment and I really wanted to go
because I was a obscure professor at
chicago-kent College of Law and there
were all these heavy hitters there on
the panel at Stanford Law School and I
really wanted to go so I said I would
and it was as a result of writing that
paper on freedom of association that I
hit upon my interest in the 9th
amendment because the Ninth Amendment
says enumeration in the constitution of
certain rights shall not be construed to
deny or disparage others retained by the
people because I was on a panel in the
First Amendment on freedom Association
with freedom associations not mentioned
in the First Amendment so my challenge
let its freedom of assembly
yeah but not association so I thought
the Federal Society at that point was a
monolithically right-wing organization
with no libertarian dimension to it I
was wrong but I didn't know that so I
walked into the room joking but I I my
opening remarks joked about how I only
bought a one-way ticket mm-hmm thinking
might the reception of what I was going
to say was so hostile and so the
punchline to my talk about freedom
Association was because I said I know
what you're thinking what gives lifetime
appointed judges the power to say that
this is a Liberty that will be protected
and then but in the Constitution it says
and then I just said the words of the
9th amendment and this huge cheering
roar came up from the students they were
cheering I thought I must have the
federal Society pegged slightly wrong
and after that I had to decide I'm not a
joiner Nick I'm kind of a contrary and
guy you must know how that feels and so
you know I don't necessarily want to be
a member of any club that will have me
but I had to decide do I want to throw
in with the Federal Society or not
because we don't agree about everything
but the federal society is a coalition
libertarians are part of their coalition
there is very very respectful to
libertarians Eugene Meyer who is the
president of federal society his dad was
Frank Meyer who was the ADI developer of
fusion ISM to fuse libertarians with
that's their philosophy therefore I
threw in with them even though I didn't
always agree with them and they've been
unbelievably generous to me it's been
one of the greatest professional
associations of my life and they're a
wonderful organization they do wonderful
things but I will say that I believe the
organization has moved in the direction
of judicial engagement from where it
used to be things are different in the
federal society and partly because it's
a grassroots organization that reflects
the tenor of its members the national
organization is super tiny run
they don't dictate and the membership
has moved in our direction
again I'm part because of that salient
moment over Obamacare things are
different now and so the entire
organization has really moved I debated
J Harvey Wilkerson after the Obamacare
case was decided in the Rosencrantz
lecture at the Federal Society at the
ballroom of the Mayflower Hotel and
years ago if there had been that debate
versus a judicial restraint guy and me
he would have had the room and I would
be the renegade that day people will
tell you the room was with me and he was
the renegade and that was a sea change
an intellectual sea change that has
taken place a couple of years ago I
interviewed mark touchnet Georgetown Law
professor I actually occupy his office
he left Georgetown he fled Georgetown as
I was arriving and I got to Haiti
I got his really nice office he had
about 10 years ago he wrote a book
called a court divided and it was about
the Rehnquist court and he as part of
his argument in which he he became
increasingly respectful of Clarence
Thomas who had often been kind of
dismissed as a lesser thinker and
whatnot but he said you know the Supreme
Court it has an effect but he said that
it's kind of noise around zero in that
sometimes it's slightly ahead of where
the population is going sometimes
oftentimes it's behind and it actually
just kind of ratified social change do
you think that that's accurate and if so
does that mean that a lot of the drama
that we see around the Supreme Court is
misplaced
I think it's accurate I think the
Supreme Court like all of us are
creatures of the moment we like to think
of ourselves as completely outside the
moment but we
in limits we can't be libertarians are
more outside the moment than most people
because we don't fully buy into in fact
this is not this was a something idea an
inside I got from Murray
he said that intellectuals themselves
people who are generally intellectuals
are not usually a part of the overall
majority for some reason they're out and
it's because they're out they look at
what's going on from a somewhat
outsider's perspective and they can see
what's going on differently than people
that are a part of it so you don't get
more conventionally minded than people
that successfully are nominated Supreme
Court these people are the insiders
insider there's no out I mean Justice
Thomas is unusual because he had a very
different route to the court through the
through his activities and the and the
EOC but other than that it was kind of
fluky but mostly these are the insiders
insiders they see things the way the and
and they're people who went through
their whole life cultivating their
normalcy we're not like them mm-hmm so
they're very conventional minded and
therefore they're never out too far or
there's ahead of the skis I think is the
way the metaphor works or behind you
know they really try to stay the course
because that's how they've lived their
whole life or they wouldn't be on the
Supreme Court nevertheless at the margin
the Supreme Court matters a lot sure it
ask anybody who now had you know has a
right to ask any resident of DC I just
bought my first gun last week
never bought a gun him I've shot guns
all my life my dad had guns but I never
owned one I didn't want to her need to
now I think it's a patriotic duty to
have one and I bought my first one last
week I live in the district had it not
been for a Supreme Court decision it
would be illegal for me to do what I
maybe it would happen but it'd be ten
years down the road it wasn't going to
happen
Missy they're still trying to you know
make it as hard as possible and they
won't allow concealed carry but like
other parts of the country so Supreme
Court cases do make a difference if we
had managed to strike down Obamacare it
would have made a different room final
question
you seem optimistic about the move
partly because of the Obamacare decision
but also because of this groundswell the
libertarian legal think
are you optimistic about the future and
what is the one or two things that you
can see really blocking forward momentum
I think I'm normally considered to be an
optimist
I'm actually pretty realistic I was at
Cook County State's Attorney okay I
understand what crooked courts are like
I understand what the real Lord is like
better than most academics do maybe
better than even some libertarians do so
I don't know that I'm really actually
optimistic but I just think you have to
have a positive attitude going forward
do you think we could be on the brink I
could be on the brink of going in that
could be a contracts professor again
seriously if if the court had changes
and constitutional law then veers back
off into the New Deal direction do I
still want to be beating my head against
the wall I don't know do you I mean from
your undergrad days or from working in
your father's laundry I mean do you
think the world is more or less
libertarian well I've read your stuff
Nick you know well I know what I
definitely captain I agree with you
about yes no but I'm saying you know
because for all of the incursions all of
the regulations all of the laws all of
the wars all up to this all up to that
on another level you know things are
better than they use hi I think in many
respects things are better than they
used to be I think where things are
worse than they used to be is you know
civil discourse is not as good as it was
once that's too bad I think that I think
where things are worse and where
libertarians have not factored this into
their conventional wisdom is that the
Democratic Party has become a party of
the left it wasn't really a party of the
left it was a liberal party in the
social-democratic sense of liberal it's
now become a european-style left party
since the McGovern thing happened and
then they've just taken over as well as
academia used to be liberal and now it's
left this is all bad and I think this is
one of the several factors that has led
to the Trump development because if you
have a european-style party on the left
then to have an American Conservative
Party seems tepid and somehow not
appropriate what they what if there's a
natural vacuum left
European party of the right that's very
dangerous and that's very objectionable
that ends up being worse from a
libertarian standpoint then a social
democratic party is you have a social
debt you know whatever so things have
gotten worse but on the other hand and
this is gonna make me seem like an
optimist things are darkest before the
dawn
if Ted Cruz if I'm right about Ted Cruz
being the president who might at Point
real constitutionalist to the court and
blah blah blah blah blah and all the
rest Ted Cruz probably wouldn't be close
to Donald Trump now if it weren't for
Donald Trump having cleared the field of
everybody else there's a there's a lot
there by the time this airs no people
are gonna know what happened better than
we do but there is a possibly good
scenario to come out it's a low
probability event at this point but it's
better than zero that we could actually
be in a better place a year from now
than we are today the Democrats are very
beatable right now but somebody needs to
beat them with something that's closer
to the republican constitution I talk
about in my book I think it's down to
two guys now on the right side of the
spectrum and one of them I think would
be good for this and the other one would
be terrible alright we will leave it
there and the book is our Republican
Constitution securing the Liberty and
sovereignty of We the People by Randy
Barnett thank you so much right Nick for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you